para ver cómo juntar los diagramas
regresemos al ejemplo en el que teníamos
únicamente dos partes las cabezas y los
cuerpos supongamos que escojo esta
cabeza y este cuerpo o también puedo
tomar este cuerpo o este hagamos todas
las posibilidades observa que la parte
de abajo del diagrama tiene seis
combinaciones igual que antes y espero
que este diagrama deje muy claro que
tenemos dos opciones a escoger de
cabezas y para cada una tenemos tres
opciones de cuerpos o sea dos por tres
combinaciones utilice el siguiente
ejercicio interactivo para encontrar
cómo se vería el diagrama si tuviéramos
otro número de cabezas y algún otro
número de cuerpos